she had spoken in New York car before
and while she's had an illustrious
career so far she's already planning her
second career of being a librarian
because already this year she's read
over 100 books
and we want to do the math on that
more than two per week two point what
use our calculator come on no sorry
everyone please welcome Molly
all right friends I am Molly Huey I am
the team lead for data legal analytics
and business at Bloomberg law we call
ourselves data lab
um and since the our talk in New York my
team has gone from 4 to 12. um so we're
doing a lot of things
um I'm gonna make sure I'm not over
doing the mics here
um so
in having a team that big I do
practically none of the coding anymore
so my entire value of in coming here and
talking to you is about how to manage
your stakeholders
so please go ahead get out your devices
get out your laptops because when Mark
was talking yesterday and everybody's
like raise your hand raise your hand I'm
like I can do better than that I can do
a slido so so either get your QR code or
enter go to slido and enter that thing
and I've got a little polling question
for you
um because also like Max I do survey
data I'm wearing my surveys and data
analysis shirts which I also wore at New
York R because it is my team t-shirt and
this is what we do and I wear it all the
time so now I have a conference uniform
it's great
all right this will be up on the next
slide too when you see
yeah it's still got you it's got your
same thing on it okay so who are your
stakeholders
right when you're doing your data work
who are you targeting who's your end
user who are the people that are feeding
into your work
non-technical
I'm not surprised I'm not surprised at
all right because who's who among you is
doing data work and giving it back to
another data engineer data scientist and
I'm going oh yeah I know exactly what
you did that's awesome thanks like that
that doesn't happen
so it's kind of what tech people think
you need and what actual scientists
think you need the amount of times that
I get asked hey can you just show me how
to do this in Excel
cool people cool
um I work with almost primarily legal
analysts on Bloomberg law
um and very many of them have said we
went to law school so we didn't have to
learn about numbers
okay I gotcha that's why we call
ourselves data counselors as well and
also um in Max and donya's talk when
they kept saying DBT over and over again
my Master's is actually in counseling so
to me that means dialectic behavior
therapy so we're doing some um therapy
in a group today
um so but what I want to come and talk
to you about is how we use R and shiny
to make all of our survey data
accessible to our very non-technical
colleagues very very smart but
non-technical
so I've broken this down into a Three
A's approach the probably the majority
of the data we use is survey data right
so we're working with our legal analysts
on the front end to make sure we're
asking the right questions because none
of my data scientists are attorneys
right I can teach them how to craft a
really good question so that the data we
get back is good but I don't necessarily
know the right question to ask right so
what's what's going on in the
marketplace so
when we're talking about making data
available for everyone accessibility
right like we can't tell them to go run
a SQL script and just get the answer
like we have to make it in a way that's
usable
we have to provide appropriate training
because like I said they went to law
school so that they didn't have to do
numbers so we have to tell them how to
use the numbers how to think about the
numbers what makes sense about this to
them and then availability and follow-up
right like this is not something where
it could be like here you go see you
later have fun bye especially because a
lot of this work is being published it's
being published on the Bloomberg law
analysis Channel or on the Bloomberg law
product or being picked up by other
outside sources and so we want it to be
right
um
so by way of background I'm going to go
go way back machine I started at
Bloomberg about seven years ago
um and that was right after Bloomberg
law had gotten sorry Bureau of national
Affairs or BNA which was a legal content
publisher got acquired by Bloomberg to
make the Bloomberg law product
and when I started they hired me as the
surveys manager and they said oh we've
got these surveys we've been doing them
for 40 years
great
but this is 45 pages long and this was
the shortest one it was all paper we
would sell them individually and all the
data that we would collect we would hold
on to with the title Fist and run it in
SPSS and print these paper tables and
that's all people would ever get like
you want the day to go look at our
report thanks
terrible and also um Nick if you're
around here like your cyber security
brain is going to buzz because
um when I got there my my new boss was
like here's your file cabinet here's all
the historical data and I was like oh
this is gonna be great
paper copies of surveys with pii on them
from before I was born like why we were
holding on to this stuff it's gone now
anyway I digress so enter shiny
dashboards here's where we start talking
about are
um when we very first started doing more
legal focused work
um we got to design brand new surveys
and I was like we are not making these
paper copy reports and giving people
tables that they can't do anything with
we're gonna make them a dashboard
and so we start with like here's the
index we had a dashboard for each
specific project which was which one we
could reuse the code we could you know
it wasn't terrible from our end but it
was terrible from the end user's end
because they couldn't remember what the
link was to the dashboard they were
supposed to use and if they happen to be
able to get to this index they couldn't
remember the short name we'd made for
the dashboard for their project
and then like a year later if we're
gonna run their same survey again to
Trend it then we have to figure out how
to attach years to it it was it was a
disaster
so we had the individual surveys I'm
gonna add agile as the fourth a of our
how to make your data available to
everyone process because we had to be
real agile about this
um and when I say agile I do not mean
having a scrum master I don't have a
scrum master
um
but we did have to start doing Sprint
reviews and we did start doing
um Retros especially after newer
projects like what went right what went
wrong what can we do differently next
time
um so we're trying to be real agile
about it and we're trying to really
learn from our stakeholders like what do
you want how can we serve you better
so off of that index here's what our
original survey dashboard looked like
this is this is a shiny dashboard we use
we use qualtrics as a survey hosting
platform we get the qsf and the CSV
files of that data we ingest it
um you know scripting into a postgres
database make the tables you know use R
and shiny create these dashboards works
really well
um so you can see we you know we've got
this list of things we've got a count
we've got a percentage
um one of the things that we built in
that was super fancy was the if you see
not the biggest drop down the biggest
drop down is survey question the second
drop downs are Workforce size and
organization type these are just the
things that people like to filter on the
most are you looking at in-house
attorneys or Law Firm attorneys and from
what size of organization so that's
sorting sorting and filtering sorry I
thought I turned all of this stuff up
guess what I'm not doing a meeting right
now
um
this allowed people to do a little bit
of their own sorting and filtering but
they would still have to come to us
every time they you know they'd be like
hey I I looked at Law Firm only but can
you tell me what's happening with just
bankruptcy attorneys or just IP lawyers
and we're like yeah we can but you can't
do that yourself sorry
coming later
um
one of the things we liked about this
down here at the bottom in our dashboard
we have a copy CSV and Excel download
buttons which is fantastic it's super
easy one of our things at Bloomberg is
that we are very brand conscious
um and when we publish articles we have
we call them analysis pieces because
we're not Central news we're editorials
so we can't write news and we can't
write stories so we write analysis
pieces that get pushed out on a channel
look just like news
um but for people to know that they're
us we have a very specific branding
Bloomberg is real weird about having the
um
y-axis on the left instead of the right
of your chart and you only put the
things on the top like there and it's
got to be the certain colors and the
certain fonts so I can't do that in R I
can't give people something that they
can just download we have a program that
runs on Terminal so if any of you are
Finance people and run Bloomberg
terminal
um there's an internal program on that
called toaster I don't know why they
made it toaster but the story I tell
myself is that you put in you know
already aggregated Graphics like this
and Bing like toast you get a brand
standard graphic so that's why we made
these download buttons so that you can
look at the data and the cuts you want
and get the get data in a shape that
works to go into toaster
um
we also have a data visualization button
on here you can't use it it's not brand
standard so you can't download it and do
stuff with it but it's so helpful in
learning how to tell the story of your
data to look at the visual first right
like so we're allowing our stakeholders
and our legal analysts to be like oh
this is the story the data they're
telling this these are some things I can
drop this is where this is really going
and then they just download the data
table and make their chart from it
so that was the first iteration
the next iteration you know consistently
evolving agile Innovative multi-survey
dashboard because I was telling you that
problem with the index of you know you
can't remember where your stuff is
we ended up pulling it all into a
dashboard so looks a little different we
gave it a blue header so that it looked
different from the other one
um and we've got a whole lot of
disclaimer stuff on here like this tells
you how to use it and it tells you where
to look for things it gives you big red
um
warnings if you're you know you need to
think about coming to our team for help
with something
so what this looks like I started the
overview this is the kind of survey
Explorer piece there's a drop down and
you can select which survey you want to
look at so people only need the one link
they come to the master survey dashboard
then they use the drop down to find the
survey they want you get an overview a
question list and your responses so the
overview it tells you when it fielded it
tells you how many responses you have
overall it will link to our final
summary report when we're done with that
and the Confluence in GRS so we're like
we've got data on top of data in here
and it's great
um the other thing we have is we built
in survey analysis pieces right I told
you analysis pieces equal news but we
can't call them news so that's that's
that
um but we're getting so much data and we
have so many legal analysts that people
can look at stuff and go well I don't
know if somebody's written on that
before
come and find out it's still a little
bit of a manual process like if you
write an analysis piece you need to go
here and click the little teal add
button and you can start typing and
it'll do a type ahead it'll search the
arjira system to say oh you wrote a
piece called looking for Preparation
Edge and reconsidering law school it
pulls it up it pulls up the link on the
news channel and you can write a little
description
put your author name in there and all
you have to do is hit save and then
we've got an entire repository of all
the analysis that people have done using
survey data which is great
um yeah the next problem we had we gave
people free rein on these dashboards and
they went bananas and then the amount of
analysis I had to kill because I looked
at it and went did you realize you used
seven people
you can't do that right but they don't
know because it's you know these are not
super technical people so we built in a
sample size indicator you know you start
with your full sample you've got a nice
green box if you start using your sorts
and filters and you get down lower than
30 you get orange you get real low you
get red so we've we make this really
clear when you're not using an
appropriate sample of data
um it can't be any easier and so and
when we train people to use the
dashboard we say hey look if you see
anything other than green
please talk to me first there are ways
to talk about this there are specific
surveys that we do um every fall we do
one on litigation finance and we survey
funders and there's really only four or
five major companies that are funding
litigation in this way so having a
sample size of 20 is actually pretty
good for them but there's there's ways
to talk about it to to represent data
accurately
um when you have a little just a little
bit of it
all right
next enhancement side by sides we we
added this compare results button
because people were saying as we started
doing surveys year over year
they were either having to have two
instances of the dashboard open or like
flip back and forth so we just were able
to split the dashboard in half and you
can compare results and so you can bring
up last year's and this year's or you
can bring up this year's version twice
and look at law firms on one side and
in-house Council on the other side it's
really nice
um
the only thing it doesn't do is
crosstabs
wait for it just wait for it
across devs
um
when I gave a very similar talk in New
York this summer this crosstab dashboard
was not yet live I was like guys this is
beta don't tell anybody about it yet it
is now live our legal analysts have been
trained on it people are using it and it
is fantastic
um so what we get is you can choose
basically your columns and your rows on
your crosstab dashboard we've built in a
very similar
um color coding so that you know people
just know if you see yellow orange red
you got to come talk to us before you
cross things we've also built in
um some guard rails where you can do
multi-select questions and single select
questions but you can't do things that
have logic ahead of them right so that
people know the universe they're talking
about this has given us a lot of good
training opportunities to help people
understand the data that we have who has
answered which questions and how to talk
about it
um
so I wanted to bring this one up site
you can see this big red warning don't
make comparisons across groups without
talking to data lab uh because when we
put a multi-select question in there
people are like oh you did this and this
and this and this like yeah no the same
person may have selected multiple of
these so again training opportunities to
tell people how to use
multi-select data single select data and
have it shown in a in a really good way
um okay let's see what else do I have on
here
oh because crosstabs dashboard is so fun
we made this so that it also does
um
what am I looking for this one
um central tendency so you can you can
get
percentages for everything you can also
get central tendency on it which is
super cool it also has the um
all your copy paste download and a
column visibility which is really cool
because if you decide like I really only
want to see the people that are actively
seeking new jobs or open to other offers
like I don't really care about these
people you can hide them from your
download which is pretty cool because
again if you're taking this and you know
dropping it into toaster for a brand
standard chart you don't want all that
extra data
um this is also new we uh I was telling
to people earlier when I have another
really big presentation on Monday to our
leadership about like what we're gonna
do for the next five quarters and what
my team's value is and what we're
building
this is really helpful so this is
looking at the analysis pieces this is
using our Adobe analytics data and our
jira data and combining them and saying
okay
pieces that we put out like either our
team writing it or us helping other
legal analysts on other teams writing it
but with survey data those pieces with
survey data have like
probably about double the amount of
unique visitors to our site and more
average views like those pieces kick it
out of the park so everybody should be
doing that
um another thing I don't have visualized
but another metric we used was we put
UTM codes on the on the end of links in
analysis pieces when it's driving people
back to the Bloomberg law product so say
we write a story on like attorney
well-being right like oh mental health
is going down all these things are
really hard go back to our you know
lawyer well-being page on product we've
got a little code on there that can show
that they came from that analysis and
went to product
our pages that we own
are five of the top ten on all of the
product because they get so many
clickbacks from pieces like this so
having that data to tell our end
stakeholders like writing these like
newsy stories on you know what a lot of
attorneys would feel like are kind of
touchy-feely things like are you looking
for new jobs are you burned out like how
are you sleeping these days
people like to read it and it drives
people back to platform you know so they
may not necessarily buy our product
because of it but it's building
awareness and it's building brand equity
and that's super important
um so just quick recap we went from
Three A's to four because agile's
important make your data accessible
appropriately train your stakeholders on
both the data that you're giving them
and how you're displaying it and what
they need to be doing with it
be available for follow-ups you know
they should know how to contact you they
should know that it's okay to ask
questions even ones that they think are
stupid I get lots of those and I I tell
people it's the most fun because if they
have that question other people have
that question
and then be agile right like learn and
listen to your stakeholders be willing
to make mistakes and be like yeah we
were wrong about this we're going to
change it next time
and that is it